people16 hommage
non stéphane richer n'a pas engagé
l'homme invisible pour l'accompagner au
piano ses nouveaux musiciens qui ont
l'avantagé de ne pas trop picolé et de
ne pas péter dans le bus en tournée sont
des machines automates programmé pour
jouer en direct sur de vrais instruments
c'est comme cuisiner à la télévision ça
veut dire les cuisiniers il ya tous ces
produits il a déjà chez tout ça on n'a
pas vu qu'il a fait le marché et comme
est lâché il a tous là et commence à
mélanger c'est un peu ça chez tous les
oignons très peu et puis je cuisine
ceux qui connaissent bien l'oeuvre du
suicide verront un retour aux sources
il ya 35 ans au tout début de sa
carrière avant que me sort son premier
tube en france stephan eicher s'amusait
déjà à bidouiller des machines tout seul
pour produire des sons électroniques
j'ai allaité l'électronique sous mon nom
au moment où j'ai passé une nuit de
programmer un charles ix qui sonnait
comme un vecteur et là on ami m'a dit
mais tu es comprend un batteur et c'est
le moment là que j'ai pris un bon acteur
avec ces machines que je travaille
maintenant et ils sont naïfs ils sont
c'était vrai instrument qui joue mais ça
joue pas comme un vrai musicien sache où
comme une machine qui joue un vrai
instrument et il ya une mélancolie
dedans il ya connaissez le film made in
times de charlie chaplin que la machine
commence à l'époux fait
ni les gars
je vais lui même frère
jouer avec des machines qui peuvent se
dérégler à tout moment il y a un petit
côté spectacle de cirque là dedans on
craint pour l'artiste qu'il tombe de son
trapèze ou que le lion referme sa gueule
sur lui au mauvais moment et c'est avec
cette fragilité que dans un spectacle on
produit de l'émotion